oh and i think it's better to love
people for who they could be
i think so it's it's better to love
in other words you know you know the
moral shortcomings of your friend
but you are going to love him for who he
can be
well i mean when you look it's
complicated right because you love
people and they have their shortcomings
and their vulnerabilities and you have
to take that as a package but look
if you're someone's friend if you're
really someone's friend
and they betray themselves you're you're
unhappy with them for doing that because
they've sacrificed their better self for
their lower self and if you're a real
friend you don't
that doesn't sit well with you so i
don't know
to what degree we love each other
because we see the ideal in
someone else and they're trying to
encourage that forward but i know in my
clinical practice
you know there's a psychologist carl
rogers a famous psychologist and he
he propounded this theory of
unconditional positive regard that you
should have that with your clients
unconditional positive regard
and i thought through that a lot i
thought no that isn't right it
i get what he was doing i am a great
admirer of carl rogers and
his work taught me a lot but my sense in
therapy was
the best in me is serving the best in
you yeah yeah
and so what i'm going to help you do is
separate the wheat from the chaff
you know you and i will both decide what
ideal we're pursuing in relationship to
your life i don't want to impose that on
you be
it has to be a consequence of dialogue
because i don't know you
and you're a particular person and your
direction is
your particular direction it can't be
mine that would be wrong
but once we've established your
direction and your ideal
then part of what we're doing in
dialogue is to separate out
what is unworthy of that in you and i
i i can't see how you can how you don't
do that with your friends and with the
people that you love
you have to but it's hard because you
love them and you know that the things
you say could hurt them
and the last thing you want to do is
hurt the people you love
and so sometimes you put a band-aid
on these cuts with like a a baby lie
and it's selfish if you really want to
help that person you would tell them the
[ __ ] truth you deal with that
discomfort they would deal with the
discomfort and then they'd get better
and then you guys would be better
yeah or you get or you get sophisticated
enough in your
in your ability to do that so that you
you can serve
both the masters we talked about at the
same time you can tell the truth but you
don't do it in a way that's damaging
yeah i mean that's hard let's not make
any mistake about it it's this is very
very difficult
that's a tight role i do think like i
thought a lot about friendship and about
about you know if something good happens
to you and you have a friend you can go
tell them and they're happy for you
and that's because they want things to
be better for you right they're not
jealous they're not upset about it
yeah and and i do think that we see
we see the we see the ideal in people
that we love and we try to call that
forward i believe that to be the case i
think that's right
yeah i now you got me thinking about
like friends and
i'm trying to understand like when i
know that i really
like love somebody as a friend and uh
there's like a weird protective instinct
that kicks in
where i i have this like
this not vision but like you know when
you have this like imaginary play that's
going on your head
this scenario has never worked out often
times it happens
you know after an act right like what i
would have said to that guy who
embarrassed me or something like that
but like
i'll have this little play in my head
where somebody does something to that
person that i love
and then i inflict some sort of pain
on that person to to demonstrate to the
person i love
that nobody can do anything to them
without me doing something
and i'm looking at this i'm like it's
kind of like barbaric that i gotta like
beat somebody up to prove that i love
somebody
but i wonder if that's like instilled in
our dna it's like the people that become
part of our tribe
we want them to know that they're safe
that they're protected
and that that safety and that protection
is i think that
all that's i look i think that's that's
part of
that's part of the hero myth as far as
i'm concerned is to protect your
territory against the barbarian
interloper right the evil barbarian
and there is something about that that
could go terribly wrong obviously but
there is something that's noble and
heroic about it
a lot of that that instinct has to be
transmuted up into the religious domain
i think essentially so what does that
mean well because
you do want to protect the people that
you love but it isn't precisely that you
want to protect them against
the bad person who might come along it's
that you want to protect them from
malevolence itself
right it has to be abstracted upward you
can't beat up
an idea or a feeling you can beat up a
bad guy right but you can't beat up
bad behavior that they're doing well so
so you so you know you
you play out the fantasy in a concrete
way but but there's something in it that
can be elevated
yeah so if you're trying to make a child
confident and competent
then you are in fact helping them fend
off
malevolent incursions against them right
and so that is what you're doing
yeah but you can do it in a manner
that's that's sophisticated
you